all right we have our first question um
so one question has come to my mind
recently concerns plastic china has
stopped accepting our trash and we have
a great Pacific Garbage Patch and a
great Atlantic Garbage Patch and a great
Indian Ocean Garbage Patch it doesn't
get any press where Mauritius is and I
just wonder seeing as plastic doesn't
completely ever biodegrade what does
that look like going forward on I've
been asking this question as a financial
person where's the money and cleaning up
the ocean and and and how do we get to
that part where we are actually
incentivized to clean this [ __ ] up
um so a couple of things I think have an
interesting perspective and whether
actually the plastics are actually
degrading or are there new forms of
bacteria or microbes appearing in our
oceans that never existed that and we're
now feeding off the plastics which i
think is an interesting perspective but
but I think no I think you're spot on
you know one of the big challenges is
how do we create the economic you know
mechanisms and incentives where the
plastic can be seen as either a resource
that can either be recycle to put
through or I mean so I think the broader
consensus on what's happening with
plastics is that at some stage you know
ten thousand years from now there will
be a layer around our seabed and our
surface where it's been an era of
plastics right then you know it's clear
that the global value systems are now
shifted that we're in remote in a
remarkably short period of time which
one went last two or three years we went
to plastics being one of several issues
to be you know plastic being a defining
issue in many countries where there's
such strict policies have been put in
place like in China like in Rwanda and
Kenya where they've banned plastic pads
here in California so we chose I'm
confident that we'll move to an era you
know a post play
the Kirov very quickly and so there's
you know two parts to answer your
question one is how to incentivize the
economics in that post plastic era so
how do we make sure we're not developing
materials that are more damaging because
they may have a greater carbon footprint
so for example there's a lot of people
developing drawers made out of bamboo
but that bamboo H has a higher water
footprint or carbon footprint versus you
know paper but paper used as a form of
glue and that glues actually toxic it's
banned in Europe versus seaweed and
algae and some of that small system so
yeah no more one is how do you move to
that new economy and I think that's an
interesting model to actually create
economic incentives through kind of
value shifts to build alternatives
number two is then what do you do with
what exists right now with plastics in
the oceans to what extent is there kind
of market mechanisms for that so that
you can use the plastics and it can be
recycled in as you know bitumen or
something in the in the streets or is
there going to be is that something
where you just need a public
intervention and a multilateral fund to
actually go out and make it becomes a
public gold good to clean that up so I
think that's gonna be the that's gonna
be the challenge I think in terms of
post plus I am now confident I wasn't
two or three years ago but I am now
confident that we will find new
alternatives to plastics I think there's
a lot of innovation in the biotech world
I think the economic mechanisms on the
cleaner still has to be worked out and
I'm not yet seen a comprehensive package
I've seen a lot of experiments but
nothing at scale that's going to scale
up so I'll have to talk to you offline
if you've got ideas about that just just
real quickly since Nashawn sort of
alluded to so you know scientifically
what's going to happen I'm not sure
anyone knows I had the good fortune to
be in an event last week where I was
able to see presentations by very
different scientists than what I am
which is a biochemist and in particular
what struck me were people showing off
their seafloor mud samples so these
cores of mud that are used there can be
correlated to tree rings in some cases
they're a history of what's been
deposited in the ocean and I think that
we're going to have the human plastic
the Anthropocene plastic
lair that you know if our species
continues in the deep into deep time
we'll look back and say oh yes that's
when you know our ancestors follow the
oceans with plastics and there's you
know a layer of particles but what's
interesting is that the concern about
micro plastics in seafood is actually
driving a lot of innovation and
incentivizing innovation in in in fish
farming of one sort or another in
artificial seafood replacement products
in fish fish grown in you know in in the
laboratory
you know from individual cells and so in
a way the problem with micro plastics is
incentivizing you know hopefully some
technologies that will help us to
restore fisheries you know maybe in a
best-case scenario so I think we're
stuck with the layer of plastic probably
but but but this is this is may this has
forced us to think of creative ways that
that we can protect ourselves from the
plastic and in doing so we might we
might help fix some of the problems
we've created I'll just just one bead
which is you know we say fight
capitalism with a better capitalism and
certainly with regulation too and
incentives but we have a plastics
company that is fully biodegradable
fully compostable edible plastic one
before I came together I worked with
adidas a lot on these shoes which are
from reclaimed ocean plastic there are
ways to fight this problem with better
capitalism itself as well I am I wanted
to know what you think is a relationship
between trauma that we have and the fact
that we do eat animals who are suffering
and you know we're talking about
connection with nature and nature is
speaking and so we have billions of
animals that that are killed I'm not
sure exactly the statistic but we have
every day maybe
because we eat then so the it's really
easy to stop eating animals and decrease
a lot of pain in the world as well as
climate change environmental degradation
in the oceans so I'm just wondering how
I mean that's my opinion and so how much
does trauma have to do it's a fact that
we just can't stop eating meat and
that's causing so much drama we'll later
find out what happens when we
continuously eat animals that are
traumatized themselves in tiny little
cages yeah and then it's slaughtered I
don't have an answer to that but I get
what you're feeling and there's a I
think there's a great bit of dr. Yoon's
ideas on this that you can read about as
I empathize very much with the point of
view that we pick up this behavior
pattern like a thought virus and we are
not strong enough when young to fight it
or our own need for personal care and
self-care prioritizes over this concern
that sits in the back of our mind
forever you know and just and I've
written about the times my kids when
they were young we're going through
processing this I think the one thing
that is elsewhere out there is culture
and people wanted to preserve culture
and in their culture they farmed this
ate that my wife is Cajun she grew up on
three foods her family's been in the
industries she doesn't want to lose her
culture Liz here you know
wants to hang on to her culture so it's
not that it's this or that it's her
culture it's her style her people want
her identity and I do think the burden
like we have an indie bio obviously many
plant protein companies and alternative
ways of dealing with this with cell
based meats and hybrid products but what
we need very important to do is you know
I keep saying you can't feed the world
one hipster at a time we need to find a
way to try to throw that out there like
a joke but like glad it got a laugh but
but it's very important that we enable
cultural expression and not and not be
sort of have an impaired list approach
to telling people what to do we need to
enable their way to stay in touch with
their culture through these new foods
that were making which is I think really
really really important there was a
comment about China moving very rapidly
and environmental issues could you
elaborate on that yeah so on China
obviously China's very complicated
country right so in the sense that China
effectively has you know a big provinces
in Hong Kong Macau for trying to make
decisions there's a group of seven the
state council which is the cabinet goes
through down to provincial governments
and so when a decision takes place at
the top it has to cascade through
several layers you've probably read a
lot about the anti-corruption clamped
down in China the last kind of four or
five years a lot of the anti-corruption
clamped down has mainly been around
environmental standards so what's been
happening has been a lot of you know
factories and others have been skirting
environmental standards in terms of you
know effluent and waste and so because
of various things about corruption and
pain inspectors and so that has been
where a lot of that clamp down has
actually taking place so number one
we're seeing signals from the very top
that they're getting very serious on you
know environmental crime and clamping
down of that number two indicators of
the environment is now getting reported
to the very highest level in a way that
doesn't exist in the US or in Europe
today
so under the Paris agreement we're now
talking about these what's called
nationally defined contributions there's
all sorts of debate about how you're
going to verify and validate what's
being tracked
but in China there's a very complex set
of metrics that's reported in in the
same way that today a central bank you
know the Federal Reserve in the u.s.
tricycle financial transaction they're
trying to do that in China for the
environment right and so that so that's
kind of a second signal that that's
being done and yes they're gonna get it
wrong to begin with in a different level
of measurement but at least
directionally and then number three from
the very top premier G who's the
president right now he defined a as you
know China has a five-year plans but he
defined a 25-year vision for China and
he called this the beautiful China
vision and so in Chinese I know others
probably speak better than I do
but he talked about the green mountains
of gold and blue rivers of silver and
that concept of an ecological a
beautiful China was meant to be a signal
that China can only be successful
financially if the mountains go back to
being green and the rivers go back to
being blue and that's been an extremely
powerful concept that's really
galvanized all of China in a way that
we're just not seeing in the US or in
Europe it's very fragmented here in
terms of debate but from a top-down
perspective that's what we're seeing in
China yes there'll be things that will
go wrong things will not go you know in
a straight line but we've seen a lot of
progress in the last five years I've
certainly have all those who travel to
China and certainly from the very top
we're seeing that that willingness
that's a story to galvanize people here
hi thank you so much for being here I
know we were talking about you know the
sense of like digitality and like our
interstates and I was I'm kind of trying
to understand like what your thoughts
were on what it means to have a digital
sense of well-being and and you know
what what are some metrics or ways that
we can actually like measure that and
there's I think like a lot of
externalities when it comes to the way
that we interact with you know our
products like our cell phones like the
computer and like the Internet and not a
lot of I think clarity in how these
things are affecting our lives and and
whether it's possible to have that
embedded within new companies that are
starting and and new Internet companies
that are starting and being able to
measure and track that or if that's
something or if that's a solution that
can only come from the top down or I
mean there's a lot in there it's a hard
hard question that I just I think for me
it it goes back to what we I suppose is
what we're building collectively and we
built this these incredible prediction
machines is what marks or defines this
digital empire we've created right it's
the ability to ingest lots of data and
then predict one step ahead and for me a
metric of well-being is how we're using
that to solve NP hard problems I I think
that that that from a regulatory level
if they're that it has many regulatory
implications for instance and the other
would be security and I think there
again I don't have any answers this idea
of technology versus the state and
coming back to paternalism how much
right does the government or a tech
company have to entering our bedrooms or
entering our thought processes and who
who governs that and with data the good
thing is and with accounting and say
even blockchain is that for the first
time we're looking at personalization at
scale so there might be opportunity for
a decentralized regulation of these
these prediction machines and so I I I
think that the scope there where where
we can transcend governments as well as
corporates to do monitor and to regulate
these these engines I think from a
scientific standpoint too I see this all
the time a lot of these software
packages and even apps have really
transformed science in a good way
you know basic scientific research and
when thinking about that I would I
suppose apply some basic test does this
platform technology and you know
computational technology does this allow
people to do deeper thinking or devote
more time to deeper thinking than they
otherwise would and you know some of the
software that aggregates scientific
manuscripts in digital form for instance
and and in the law legal industries has
been transformed by this - it's amazing
not to have to go to a university
library and photocopy journal articles
it's nice to be able to aggregate them
on your computer the saves time to do
you know substantial thinking about
things other than which stack is a
particular journal located in the
Medical Sciences Library so I think that
that that we do see these digital
advances really improving things and I
think a friend of mine in the audience
has thought a lot about machine learning
enabling helping scientists to
assimilate
literature that's that's too vast for
someone who didn't grow up in the field
- to understand and I I think there's
there's really positive things in that
space so I mean if I was to apply a
litmus test and I was looking at say
digital companies to fund if I were as a
VC which I'm not maybe I would apply
this this litmus test does this make
people more
fulfilling their creative potential
streaky I look at it very much on the
level of consumption versus production
from the point of view of an author and
one of my books was called nurture shock
new thinking about children and one of
the things that jumped out of that is
the incredible power for children to do
extended play especially extended play
what it was co-authored meaning you
could share authorship of an imaginary
scenario it wasn't you maybe were
borrowing from you know some TV show
you'd seen or a cartoon but then you
would make making it your own and the
way I look at our digital life is very
much through this lens of how much of it
were just taking in versus how much of
it are we and and when I say interacting
I don't mean liking and reposting right
so the big difference room listening to
a podcast entering almost a transcendent
state half of what you're thinking about
is what you're hearing on the podcast
and half is your own memory banks and
processing happening simultaneously it's
a state of mind just state of mind that
again is very one person could be
scrolling through news and just being
like an idiot another person could be
scoring through news it looks the same
maybe even looks the same to your stupid
crawling AI that says they know what
people are doing and thinking but it's
not the same and the other person is
really heavily thinking engaging with
that material and bouncing around and
there's a meaningful difference between
self-directed navigation through digital
devices to learning because you're
curious to be able to take in lots of
information and it kind of coming at you
fundamentally looking at the fact that
when I wrote nurture chakra started at
work in 2007 your average child United
States was watching 3 hours and 40
minutes of linear television a day that
was coming at them totally in other
people's control we as you know big
smartypants old people moralize if
oh they're on their phones all the time
and I'm like what do you 10 years ago 3
hours and 40 minutes a day of sitting
there sucking in cereal commercials and
whatever the Nickelodeon channel wanted
to give you and at least I'd rather have
their thumb navigating it and taking
control of it and being able to
self-direct and learn a few things so I
think we have been really careful about
how we interpret this stuff even on the
overflow of our email box like at least
a lot of it you can actually act on you
can say I disagree or I want to schedule
a meeting or yes that will be there to
pick up my kid whatever it is at least
it may be nonsense please active and
that's very different than just being a
receiver a consumer and not a producer
not co-creating with the world that's
coming in and do these tiny little tests
for your digital well-being where you
yourself decide for a day that you're
just gonna turn your phone completely
off and you're gonna go and read a book
or you're gonna go into muir woods or
the ocean or whatever you're gonna do
and when you do that to see how you feel
and just tap into your own being and how
you feel and just keep doing these tiny
little behavior changes and seeing how
you feel and just that quantified self
process of taking your own control of
your well-being in the digital tech era
one of the most important things young
people can learn how to do hi so if you
look at in the history of Education you
find that it's kind of originally
started to make good soldiers and good
factory workers and over time that has
been even further optimized by the
systems that we have and Facebook isn't
strictly intentionally optimized to make
you like feel bad about yourself and
disempowered but it does because people
you know post their highlights and don't
tell you so much about their struggles
what do you see is a way to kind of
train people to realize that they are
empowered and they can do things and
that they have the ability to affect the
world
make education affordable I mean we as a
society engineered a system where we
knew that nothing was more important
than people getting educated and that
same period of time we made education so
expensive that people are saddled with
that that mission or that enrolment
rates are going down it's it's the
McCook to me like one of the most
fundamental things if you look at many
many societies that transform themselves
it was through using education in a tie
for a tough economic period Argentina
has done it Ireland's Donegal country
after country having done it and the
it's it's savage that what we've done to
sort of make education and accessible
and to me seems fundamentally designed
to keep people from getting educated so
that they don't vote with an educated
mind so also to follow on that I would
say that we need to maybe reconsider
as proper education so I think that much
of what is done is training and not the
training is bad but but I think that a
proper education a useful education is
one that teaches you to think critically
and to bring together insights from
disparate fields and I think that having
a well-prepared mind is more important
for making innovations of any sort in
any field than it is that you know you
know specifically you know how to do a
particular task in the laboratory that
that can be learned but but being able
to toggle between big picture and
details that matter and being able to
deconstruct problems and and in fact
identify perverse incentives is
something that's sorely lacking are just
not common enough in education and and
if we had a movement more towards the
basics of how to think you know elements
of logic
maybe maybe many things would be better
and mother nature is the best teacher
yeah a number of years ago I read an
article that claimed that the British
common law countries which is America
England and Australia had the extremely
high level of climate deniers and if you
sort of in a sort of made sense to me
and I think that we here in America
today are so skeptical and we've created
a system it's good because questioning
Authority has its qualities about being
an entrepreneur and it has its bright
side but we've become this society of
not believing that vaccines are good
climate is climate change is real so
this this we've we have this system
that's capitalism and democracy rolled
into one
that has animal in this common law that
has created a lot of perverse incentives
for us to just be skeptical
pathologically skeptical so any comments
on that just a quick one I think that
you know around that around that problem
we we need to we need to teach people
that facts are not the result of an
online poll like you know there are
basic facts that can be you know proven
to the level of theory or supported the
level of theory by tested hypotheses and
these are fairly immutable unless you
know great evidence as the contrary is
provided and people just don't get to
decide that what they hope is right is
the truth is the truth and so I think
that that somehow this gets the
educational problem teaching people
basic things like cause and effect and
the you know coming up with testable
hypotheses and testing them and
empirically finding out what the closest
that our measurements and abilities
allow us to determine is truth is
something important especially when it
comes to things like climate change and
so so many other key issues I think the
opinion in fact have been blurred in
many areas where they shouldn't and so
how do you get that scientific thought
process so that scientific rigor into a
non-scientific mind well you know that's
a really good question I don't have a
good answer except to say that I think I
think that inherently all people are
scientists whether they they realize it
or not I mean we we do simple which has
simple hypotheses every day mostly
unaware that we're doing so and people
who may have a non-quantitative mind
let's just say someone who's really
creative in different ways may be
socially or kinetically they test
hypotheses all the time if you look at
an athlete doing whatever athletic event
they are there there's micro hypotheses
in every move they make so I think the
thing with crossing the street you know
crossing the street do you need to pick
up your speed a little bit in order to
make the countdown as well in San
Francisco yes but but I I do so I think
that I think that to answer your
question if one could intervene it would
be to teach people with different types
of intelligence their different
distributions of different intelligence
types that all of the different
intelligence they use in some way
queries hypotheses and that's that's
sort of like baked into life and that's
an that's an okay thing and I think that
that if you did that people who are not
traditionally quantitative science who
would we would think of as science
oriented people would realize that that
this is sort of this is fundamental to
all thinking no matter what type I would
actually not go so bottom-up which I
think will play out in a very long run
it's it's a top-down problem for me it's
it's leadership it the political system
is has this perverse incentive to to
obfuscate this boundary between opinion
and fact and especially in diverse
countries that's I think that's where
the problem is looming and and a joint
coordinated international based line
allies
is what is needed to basically instill
in our leadership that the Sun does rise
from the east and sets in the west and
that that's where I would approach it
from was I haven't heard this but in
Neesha and you'd notice as well but you
know why would climate denying be
associated with countries that are
historically white male dominated
speaking English a Queen's English how
could that be well the easiest answer is
that they were in power they were
running the coal companies 20 major
energy companies in the world dominate
the energy industry and they have the
ten of the top 15 and and therefore
their breeding denial like if there's an
Occam's razor to that that I would
suggest is that work I'm tempted to say
things like we did kind of mistakenly
made climate science like really
sophisticated climate models need to be
used like no co2 trap see simple like
whether we wanted to characterize it as
like really exotic science or not a
wheat where we actually needed to back
in the 80s in the early 90s when that
was sort of all we have we didn't have
all the monitors that we do today but in
that period of time for betraying it is
extremely complex that only a few people
can understand only experts can tell you
this that that meta messaging was doomed
if you if you do if you try to convey
the masses of anything where that's the
first thing coming out of your mouth and
going back to your point about how do we
all become scientists or can have more
scientific thinking of it I'd say that
scientific thinking may sound like a
lofty goal but
maybe we can all do reasoning and
reasoning sounds like a little easier
and maybe when we explain reasoning to
others that tells us something about our
inner selves which was an earlier topic
but let me ask a panel a question that's
about your inner selves and so this week
when you were faced with a perverse
incentive because we all do and we have
choices and I find it really interesting
when we had to translate principles the
choices in our everyday lives
what was perserve a perverse incentive
that you saw and what was your imperfect
choice probably in that case and why did
you choose the way you chose so I won't
yeah so you write that I think every day
in every week there are kind of big
choices and certainly this week is no
shortage in terms of involved in you had
an introduction a big treaty around kind
of life on the oceans and there's a big
perverse incentive and regulatory
capture about those who want to do
seabed mining for example so even though
they proclaim to be doing a sustainable
ocean economy it's clear that it's not
it's just and so when you're faced with
those choices I think one of the big
questions at the core of what you're
asking is where's your courage do you
have the courage to stand up do you have
the courage to let go the institutions
or the organizations or the labels that
you have and to stand up for your values
and whether those values and what does
that North Star come from you know to
the points about kind of education I had
some themes and some questions on
education and had a lot about the kind
of rational thinking that so this
session that we were in in in India one
of the big kind of revelations that the
the Dalai Lama has had what was
interesting it's a small group around
science and spirituality and he
recognizes one of his big legacies is
that the Tibetan people may may be a
people in in exile for however many
years whether it's 10 years decades
centuries thousands of years and so
they're now reconciling the fact
they no longer get to me in the homeland
of Tibet which have been ravaged by
climate change in terms of the melting
of the ice caps are changing the
landscape as well as cultural and
political factors and so one of these
big legacies is how's he then trained
the 10,000 Buddhist monks or outside
into the values of science for example
because he sees that the in Tibetan
culture I want the big assets is kind of
that rational thinking but also
scientific thinking how do you find
something which is compatible but rather
than just looking at the rational side
he's introduced this new education
curriculum around the social emotional
and ethical side of thinking which you
think is undervalued in our modern
education system and so to the point
that I don't know it did yourself
somebody else was making about are we
creating workers of the futures are we
preparing to have the adults of the
future in terms of leadership how can
those sorts of tools that we're not
comfortable with give us the courage to
address those perverse incentive because
even if you encounter perverse
incentives it's not your left brain
logical thinking that will overcome that
it's gonna be something with a bit more
creative on even a little bit lower
within you that may not be taught at
school today that will need to develop
so yeah I can tell you when I face every
day and one that became apparent to me
last week when my mom was here and she
asked me when I was moving back to India
and I think this perverse incentive of
if I care so much for the global South
why am I sitting in San Francisco right
and that is a very very tough one and I
am here because there are D dollars
spent in India just just no R&D spending
where I am creatively inclined to be
with the best scientists but I also
remind myself that I'm in this basement
with the best scientists that are
working on biotechnology for human and
Planetary health and I think for me it
comes with taking pride and being an
immigrant and actually just embracing
that label of being an immigrant and in
the hopes that the science we're
creating downstairs will transcend these
colonial national waters so that's
that's I guess my best answer I can give
you but yeah that's one that
hopefully over time Americans have it
yeah so one example that I faced this
week and it always I think it faces a
lot of biotech startups is this question
about how you scale in a humane way
because if you if you have science that
has a bottleneck in it some sort or
another and any scientific process
always has a bottleneck you can increase
that aperture by just hiring people
somewhat quickly in haps hazard lis
maybe you know adequate people with
adequate skills you know to force force
that that bottleneck wider and and get
your work done but then the question the
moral question that always faces the CEO
of the company and I is how do we do
this in a way that we don't have to lay
people out if if we buy robot that
greatly increases that that slow step or
it makes that slow step no longer the
slowest in the pipeline and and and so
this this necessitates a more difficult
hiring process because instead of
optimizing for someone whose CV you know
one can check each skill that each
particular skill we optimize more for is
this person does this person show that
they can learn new things quickly and
has creativity and mental plasticity
because if you hire people like that who
are much harder to screen for in my
opinion and require just a more
difficult hiring process you end up with
something that's sustainable and I I
can't say that in my career at this and
other companies hiring people I've
always done that perfectly but I think
it's it's a moral issue that faces us
and we have to take the more expensive
route to for a better long-term outcome
I think it comes down to alternatives
what are our alternatives so when I
Drive my car somewhere
there is I feel bad about it but I think
that's the best choice for me at the
time and so what we're really committed
to downstairs here at Indy bio is
creating better alternatives so that we
don't have to make that choice in the
future and so I justify a lot of what I
do bad choices I make throughout the day
by using plastic if I drink out of a
plastic bottle or it's a horrible
horrible feeling and I'm aware of it but
I justify it by saying I'm creating more
alternatives are part of the movement to
create more alternatives to a better
future you guys are all much better than
me because my my my compromises which
great great question actually to bring
it home because I mean my compromises
are very personal every single day I
don't care my health my my creative work
my family my work colleagues my job my
extended family or let alone stuff
outside the house let alone the
environment little like like they are
fighting a war every single day for my
time and I'm compromising them and
rationalizing every single day but
without a doubt and walk around half the
time feel like I can never make
everybody happy and I'm only talking
about myself and don't have a solution
to that
especially during a period of time
Marvin and I working on a book right now
so especially at a time where I'm trying
to find some time a day to write a
thousand or two thousand words and
middle night if I need to and ice
extremely selfish to sort of like
definitely to be sitting with dinner
with people and not being present
because I'm thinking half the time what
am I going to write tonight when I get
up in the middle of night like that's
that is the nature of my life I hope not
to hurt too many people with it
in the most perverse thing that's
happened to me is that I've had the
truth obfuscated of who we are where we
come from what our purpose is and how to
connect back to that source and embody
it moving forward and I'm grateful to
indigenous wisdom that I've been taught
recently that has helped me better
embody that on a moment-to-moment basis
and that's the end of the Q&A so thank
you to everyone for your questions
thanks to our panelists another round of
applause for everyone all right and now
before we start the work groups Gregg
bill key yes come on up Gregg has some
words to say about the remembering
rosalind Franklin project that it's in
partnership with bio captivate I'm
working right now with young Lewis and
Lauren and deskey over there on the
early development for a new project for
bio captivate that is going to be
launched in late 2019 as you can see
there it's called remember Rosalind and
that is the name of our website remember
Rosalind org and I'll read the
description here because it sums things
up pretty well
remember Rosalind is an interactive
serialized presentation using augmented
reality and online learning resources to
explore this story science and
controversies surrounding Rosalind
Franklin's contributions during the race
to discover the structure of DNA and how
they can be relevant today and what
we're looking at this project is being a
collaboration between scientists artists
and historian historians and it'll be
presented over a three-month period via
updates
our website and also an augmented
reality app and the audience will be
able to interact with us via online
forums posting comments will be able to
ask questions were in just the early
stages of developing this right now so I
suggest if you'd like more information
on it go to the website remember Roselyn
org and sign up for the mailing list and
there'll be more information coming in
the months ahead and also tonight we'll
set up a little demo so you can see one
of the augmented reality pieces actually
up live and also you'll be able to sign
up for the mailing list really looking
forward to developing and presenting
this project they think it's going to be
an interesting and engaging project for
all types of audiences and we hope you
guys join us Thanks
[Music]
[Music]